linda apporte six bouteilles de bière
vides à son dépanneur des bouteilles de
bière allemande sur lesquels on trouve
la mention consignés québec
le propriétaire du dépanneur la regarde
d'un air contrarié ces bouteilles vertes
sont différentes des bonnes vieilles
bouteilles de bière brune des grands
brasseurs celle là il les reprend sans
rechigner
il faut dire que l'aco singh pour ses
bouteilles brune remonte à aussi loin
que les années 50
à cette époque et grands brasseurs
qu'avait créé vaincre ce système de
consigne privé au dépanneur
le propriétaire dit finalement à linda
qui ne peut fuir principauté puisqu'il
ne vend pas cette marque de bière
pourtant ils vendent autres bières
importées qui sont un souci dans des
contenants étiqueté consigny québec at
il le droit de refuser des bouteilles de
linda non les contenants consignés
québec sont régis par une loi
si un commerçant vend déjà des produits
est assignée québec
il a l'obligation d'accepter tous les
contenants consignés québec
même ceux qui le ventre le fin mot de
l'histoire
que cela plaise ou non à votre dépanneur
la loi c'est la loi